what is what is the minimum size for
something to be labeled a planet and why
is it they kept flora 37b which was only
a fraction larger than Pluto has been
labeled as an exoplanet while Pluto was
demoted to a dwarf planet yeah so a
couple of things in the 2006 definition
of a planet has to be large enough for
its gravity to make it a sphere Pluto
checks out on that Kepler checks out on
that fun but it also has to be
significant enough with its
gravitational attraction to have cleaned
out its environment in which it orbits
and Pluto has done no such thing and one
is in the Kuiper belt of other icy
bodies in the outer solar system
Pluto dwarf planet the kepler planet
real planet there you know so you just
get over that so so Kepler is not
covered in ice nicely good you could be
covered in ice but we don't surround it
yes exactly